[Musik]
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Ich habe das Hallo vergessen.
[Lacht] Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Es geht auch ohne Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es etwas Besonderes bzw. morgen,
denn ich werde heute damit anfangen und morgen fertigstellen.
Ich mache unglaubliche Käsekuchen Sticks.
Die Basis ist ein Käsekuchen, der dann geschnitten wird,
mit einem Eisstiel eingefroren wird
und dann wird er in verschiedene Schokoladensaucen getaucht,
mit verschiedenen Toppings dekoriert.
Es wird der Knaller! Ich sag's euch.
Jetzt machen wir erst einmal einen ganz normalen Käsekuchen.
Den mache ich mit Boden, also mit einem Mürbeteig.
Dafür nehme ich wieder mein ganz normales 1-2-3-Rezept.
Ich habe hier also meinen 1-2-3-Turm
aus 1 Teil Zucker, 2 Teilen Butter und 3 Teilen Mehl.
1 Ei kommt noch dazu, Vanilleextrakt und etwas Salz.
Ihr könnt diesen Mürbeteig entweder mit der Hand verkneten
oder mit so einem Messer zerhacken
oder ihr könnt einfach eine Küchenmaschine nehmen
oder auch einen Mixer mit Mixmessern. Das geht auch ganz gut.
Im Prinzip gebt ihr jetzt die Zutaten hier in die Schüssel.
Ich gebe einmal die kalte Butter hinein.
Dann den Zucker dazu.
Kurz verkneten.
[Küchenmaschine]
Es ist völlig normal, dass die Maschine jetzt wackelt,
da die Butter sehr kalt ist.
Da kann ich schon Vanilleextrakt dazugeben
und Salz.
Dann auch das Ei.
Dann könnt ihr direkt das Mehl einarbeiten
und den Teig einfach nur kurz verkneten.
Der soll jetzt schön kalt bleiben.
Also deswegen nicht zu lange verkneten,
sondern nur so lange, bis er schön homogen ist.
Ein ganz einfacher Keksteig.
Den könnt ihr übrigens auch,
falls ihr diese Käsekuchen-Sticks in Schokoladengeschmack machen wollt,
einen dunklen Boden machen und z.B. 50 g des Mehls durch Kakao ersetzen.
Oh! Wir machen 2 Versionen.
JOSH: Können wir da Nougat reinmachen?
SALLY: Und dann mit Nougat. Oh mein Gott!
Okay, wir machen eine helle und eine dunkle Version, Josh.
Ich werde dann beim 2. Teig
einfach 50 g Mehl ersetzen durch 50 g Kakao
und statt Vanille Tonka Wonka. Oh!
Tonka Wonka nehmen. Yes!
[Musik]
Normalerweise mache ich bei Mürbeteigen immer nur das Eigelb rein
und kein Eiweiß, aber bei dem -
der wird ja später praktisch in Schokolade getaucht.
Da möchte ich dann schon, dass der Keksteig
außen rum auch stabil genug ist. Deswegen ein ganzes Ei.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt, kann man es auch einmal weglassen.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier den Teig nur kurz zusammenkneten.
Also ich lasse ihn jetzt in der Maschine nicht zu lange kneten,
Dann müssen wir nur noch kurz zusammenfügen.
Jetzt darf er kühlgestellt werden.
Dafür drücke ich ihn gerne flach auf einem Teller.
Kann ihn dann abdecken und 30 Minuten kaltstellen.
Ich mache jetzt noch den 2. Teig mit Kakao und Tonka Bohne.
[Musik und Uhr]
Der Teig kühlt
und ich kann jetzt schon einmal die Käsekuchenmasse zubereiten.
Das ist jetzt hier eine Standardmasse,
also der ganz normale Basic Käsekuchen.
Ihr könnt den natürlich auch direkt verfeinern mit
Zitronenabrieb, mit verschiedenen Aromen - das bleibt euch überlassen.
Aber ich lasse ihn jetzt so Basic,
damit er später zu jeder Geschmacksrichtung passt.
Das Ganze mache ich später noch
- ich zeige es euch gleich noch einmal - in dunkler Version.
Dafür nehme ich 125 g weiche Butter, 170 g Zucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt, 4 Eier, etwas Zitronensaft, 500 g Quark,
200 g Joghurt - da habe ich den Sahnejoghurt -,
45 g Stärke und 200 g Sahne.
Im Prinzip könnt ihr - ich habe hier jetzt Joghurt mit dabei.
Ihr könnt auch Schmand nehmen, ihr könnt auch 400 g Sahne nehmen.
Aber ich finde es auch so ganz gut,
weil der Joghurt das Ganze so ein bisschen auffrischt.
Okay, was mache ich zuerst?
Erstmal die weiche Butter mit dem Zucker verrühren.
[Küchenmaschine]
Sobald die Zutaten verrührt sind, Vanilleextrakt und die Eier zufügen
und immer ein Ei nach dem anderen, damit es sich gut verbinden kann.
[Musik]
Dann gebe ich jetzt einfach alle anderen Zutaten dazu
und kann die Masse ganz kurz geschmeidig rühren.
Sie ist dann schon fertig.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt die erste Masse, die zweite Masse.
Und hier füge ich jetzt einfach noch Tonka Wonka und Kakao dazu,
also wie beim Teig schon.
Dann habe ich eine Vanille- und eine Schokoladencreme.
[Musik]
Jetzt hole ich meine zwei Teige und dann geht es ans Füllen.
Aber erst einmal putzen.
Guck, schon sauber!
So macht das Backen Spaß - immer gleich saubermachen!
Jetzt könnt ihr euch eine Springform oder einen Tortenring nehmen.
Ich mache das ganz gern im Tortenring, den auch 26 cm einstellen.
Am besten stellt ihr den übrigens hier ein.
Ich weiß, ich mache das auch immer in der Luft,
aber es ist auf einer glatten Unterlage immer besser.
So, dann nehmt ihr euch euren Teig,
könnt auch die Hände leicht bemehlen.
Jetzt solange Rollen formen und diese an den Rand drücken.
So forme ich erst einmal den Rand.
[Musik]
Einmal ringsherum.
Der wird dann mit den Fingern so nach oben gedrückt,
und zwar schon so etwa 4-5 cm hoch,
damit die Käsekuchenmasse auch hineinpasst.
Schön gleichmäßig drücken und darauf achten,
dass am Rand nicht so ein Wulst entsteht,
sondern der Rand richtig schön rechteckig wird.
Dafür drückt ihr z. B. hier mit dem Daumen am Rand hinein
und dann entsteht da dieser rechte Winkel.
Den Rest einfach in die Mitte legen und schön flach drücken.
Ihr könnt auch zur Hilfe eine Burgerpresse nehmen
oder einfach mit den Fingern.
[Musik]
Und hier kommt jetzt die Käsekuchenmasse hinein.
Dann kann der Kuchen auch schon direkt gebacken werden.
Ich habe den Ofen schon auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt.
Falls ihr auch eine Bosch Serie 8 habt,
dann hat er eine Assist Funktion, d. h. eine Backfunktion,
der Perfect Bake Assist.
Das bedeutet, ihr könnt da einstellen, dass ihr Käsekuchen im Ofen habt
und dann backt er von ganz alleine
und stellt die Temperatur, die Backzeit und die Heizart ein.
Der Käsekuchen wird dann immer perfekt.
Dann ist er nämlich nicht übergar, nicht roh.
Er hat die perfekte Bräune.
Also bei Käsekuchen, muss ich sagen, mache ich das echt gerne,
weil er dann perfekt wird und ich muss ihn nicht kontrollieren.
[Musik und Uhr]
Jetzt könnt ihr hier den Käsekuchen ganz kurz klopfen,
damit die Luft, die noch drinnen ist, entweichen kann.
Dann reißt er nämlich auch nicht.
[Musik]
Nach der Backzeit einfach dann den Ofen ausschalten,
den Kuchen darin noch 10 Minuten abkühlen lassen
und dann erst herausnehmen.
Ich hatte beide Käsekuchen,
nachdem sie dann auf Raumtemperatur abgekühlt waren,
habe ich sie über Nacht in den Kühlschrank gestellt
und jetzt sind sie schön kalt.
Jetzt kann ich sie direkt einmal hier herauslösen.
Wenn ihr das Ganze sommerlicher machen wollt,
könnt ihr bei dem hellen Käsekuchen z. B. auch
Zitronenschale, also Zitronenabrieb, mit hineingeben.
Ich rolle das Backpapier, die Backfolie immer darunter weg.
Den Rand hatte ich auch nach dem Backen kurz gelöst,
damit der sich praktisch mit dem Kuchen zusammenziehen kann.
Das ist ein schöner Rand, gell?
Dann kann ich jetzt hier direkt 12 Stücke schneiden.
Ich nehme jetzt hier den Einteiler als Maß.
Ich habe gerade fast 16 gemacht.
Fast hätte ich es falsch herum gehalten. [Lacht]
Immer da, wo die Zahl oben steht - also wenn die 12 oben steht,
wird er auch in 12 Stücke geschnitten.
Ich kann es damit jetzt ein bisschen andeuten,
am Rand zumindest.
Huch. [Lacht] Heute ist der Falsch-herum-Tag.
Also ich kann es jetzt hier nur am Rand andeuten,
denn der Käsekuchen in der Mitte ist tiefer als der Rand.
[Musik]
Ich sehe mich auch mit so einem Stück Schokokäsekuchen.
Ich sehe mich mit 3 Stücken Käsekuchen. [Beide lachen]
[Musik]
Damit jetzt aus dem Käsekuchen -
habe ich eigentlich schon erzählt, was ich machen will?
Noch nicht richtig, gell? Ich glaube auch nicht.
Okay, also diesen Käsekuchen habe ich jetzt geschnitten.
Der wird jetzt auf Sticks aufgespießt, eingefroren
und dann mit Schokolade und verschiedenen Toppings überzogen.
Wow! Ich habe hier ganz normale Eis Sticks.
Die gibt es so auch eigentlich überall,
diese, wo man selbst Eis machen kann oder Kuchen am Stick.
Ich glaube nur, die sind vielleicht ein bisschen zu kurz.
Deswegen habe ich hier noch Rundholz vorbereitet.
Das hole ich immer aus dem Baumarkt - so ein Buchenrundholz.
Das kann man in 5 mm, 1/3/8 cm Stärke bekommen - egal, wie.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein relatives dünnes Holz
und habe es einfach ein bisschen länger geschnitten,
denn ich denke, man braucht schon die Länge.
So, jetzt könnt ihr im Prinzip hier den Kuchen aufspießen.
So. Ich probiere es trotzdem auch einmal mit diesen.
Müsste eigentlich auch gehen, muss ich sagen,
denn er wird ja gefroren. Wir gucken einfach.
Dann kann ich den Kuchen einfrieren, damit er gleich,
wenn ich ihn in flüssige Schokolade tauche, nicht abbricht.
Diesen Käsekuchen Trend gibt es jetzt schon länger.
Es gibt Läden, die das auch verkaufen so wie...
kennt ihr noch diese Joghurtläden? Wie hieß das? Joghurteis?
Frozen Joghurt!
Da gab es ja auch Frozen Joghurt mit verschiedenen Toppings darauf.
Und so gibt es jetzt auch gerade diese Käsekuchenläden.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier ein Blech,
der bei mir auch in den Gefrierschrank passt.
Ich werde es jetzt nicht so am Stück einfrieren,
damit die Käsekuchenstücke schön einzeln gefrieren können.
Ich hoffe natürlich, dass der Stick auch ohne Schokolade hält.
Falls nicht, werde ich einfach den Stick doch in Schokolade tauchen
und dann in den Kuchen hineinstecken.
Aber das werden wir gleich sehen.
So habe ich Käsekuchen auch noch nie eingefroren,
aber so auf Vorrat habe ich schon Käsekuchen eingefroren.
Immer, wenn ich meine Backbücher mache und dann ganz viel Kuchen dahabe.
Ich meine, das meiste wird schon gegessen,
aber es gibt auch Kuchen, wie Käsekuchen,
den kann man auch super einfrieren
und dann mache ich das. Dann habe ich nämlich immer Kuchen auf Vorrat.
[Musik]
Guckt mal! Zum Stapeln nehme ich so kleine Gläser oder Becher
zwischen rein.
[Musik]
Gut. Die Käsekuchenstücke sind jetzt eingefroren
und ich habe mir jetzt Gedanken darüber gemacht,
wie ich das Topping gestalten will.
[Lacht] Da ich sehr schlecht im Entscheiden bin,
habe ich mir gedacht, wird jedes Käsekuchenstück etwas Anderes.
[Lacht] Wie sehr will sie ausrasten? Ja.
Herzlich willkommen zum Art Attack Riesenbild.
Im Prinzip - das ist jetzt natürlich übertrieben, aber für euch als Idee -
ich hätte da jetzt auch 24 Videos daraus machen können,
aber nein, ich packe euch alles in 1 Video.
Also, ich habe hier einmal
Ruby Kuvertüre, weiße Kuvertüre, Zartbitterkuvertüre,
Karamellkuvertüre - ihr könnt auch Vollmilchkuvertüre nehmen,
die mag ich aber gar nicht so sehr.
Deswegen habe ich mich lieber auf die 4 Sorten spezialisiert.
Dann habe ich zu jedem noch so Crispy Pearls,
also Schokoladenperlen, und Toppings eurer Wahl.
Also ob ihr jetzt frische Früchte nehmt oder Süßigkeiten
oder Nüsse oder einfach alles - könnt ihr selbst entscheiden.
Wichtig ist, dass jetzt die Kuvertüre auf jeden Fall temperiert wird,
das heißt, ihr nehmt 2/3 davon, erwärmt es über dem Wasserbad,
nehmt es runter und rührt das restliche Drittel ein.
Ich würde es jetzt auch so machen,
dass ich Schokoladensorte für Schokoladensorte vorbereite,
und euch einfach an meinen Ideen teilhaben lasse.
Die erste Kuvertüre, die Zartbitterkuvertüre,
habe ich jetzt schon temperiert.
Jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder in einen Messbecher einfüllen
oder in ein höheres Rührgefäß.
Ich habe jetzt einmal das hier gefunden, den Spritzbeutelständer.
Der hat ja auch, wenn ich so überlege,
schon so die Form zum guten Eintauchen,
denn in so einem Café, wo es diese Käsekuchen am Stiel gibt,
die haben natürlich eine riesen Tonne voll temperierter Kuvertüre.
Aber zu Hause ergibt es natürlich keinen Sinn,
hat man ja auch zu viel Kuvertüre übrig.
Ich habe die jetzt auch einfach in der Kenwood kurz temperiert,
aber wie gesagt, über dem Wasserbad geht es natürlich auch.
Ein paar habe ich jetzt auch über dem Wasserbad, gerade so kleine,
damit ich vielleicht andersfarbige Schokolade noch darübergeben kann.
Wir probieren es.
Jetzt bräuchte ich echt eine Konditorei mit 8 Temperiermaschinen.
Ich meine, was ihr auch machen könnt,
ihr müsst sie auch nicht komplett eintauchen.
Ihr könnt auch ein Stück Käsekuchen nehmen und übergießen
oder bepinseln, aber so ist es natürlich schon cooler.
Okay, die erste Kombination werden Giotto
- die gibt es in Hell und Dunkel - mit Mikado, habe ich mir gedacht,
und mit gehackten Nüssen.
Ein paar Giotto werde ich halbieren, sofern es geht.
[Musik]
Der wandert jetzt in die Schokolade.
Einmal komplett, genau.
Ich habe noch ein bisschen Kokosfett daran.
Ich hoffe jetzt einfach nur, dass der Stiel hält.
Ich nehme unten ein bisschen etwas weg.
Ah, ich muss es hier darauflegen. Hilfe!
Ich wollte es fast auf das Holz legen.
[Musik]
Sieht doch gut aus: Giotto Mikado!
Nummer 2: Bounty!
Hmm? Bounty mache ich auch innen dunkel.
[Musik]
Oreo! Einen werde ich zerteilen.
Oh, den werde ich hacken. Ha!
[Lacht] Jetzt rastet sie aus! Jetzt rastet sie aus!
Oh! Bei einem mache ich den Keks auseinander, wie in der Werbung.
Dann kratze ich das aus, damit ich nur die Keksbrösel habe.
Theoretisch könnt ihr auch, wenn ihr wisst, ihr macht nur eine Sorte,
dann könnt ihr z.B. auch schon den Käsekuchen innen mit Oreoboden backen.
Aber ich wollte natürlich jetzt hier richtig herumexperimentieren
Also auf jeden Fall einmal kurz zur Seite legen,
damit da nicht so diese Nasen entstehen.
[Musik]
Giotto bekommt noch ein bisschen Karamellschokolade.
Deswegen habe ich hier in den Schmelzschalen
immer noch ein bisschen Schokolade mit Kokosöl.
Heiß drüberlaufen lassen.
[Musik]
Die ersten 3 sind fertig.
Die stelle ich kühl und mache die nächste Schokolade.
Boah, jetzt flippt sie aus!
Jetzt macht sie einen Cheesecake Stick Laden auf. [Lacht]
Die werden ja sofort fest. Die kann man sofort essen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier Karamellschokolade.
Damit mache ich jetzt auch 3 Variationen.
Die erste ist Kinder Maxi King.
[Musik]
Ich bin immer so enttäuscht,
wenn ich das Bild sehe und dann das echte Produkt.
Dafür habe ich einen Karamell Cheesecake!
[Musik]
[Lacht]
Oh, so richtig golden!
Harry Styles wird ausrasten.
[Singend] The Cheesecake - you're so golden.
Okay, erst einmal hier absetzen.
Kurz sitzen lassen und dann hier hin.
Kinder Maxi King... bekommt... Haselnüsse.
[Musik]
[Sarah lacht] Das ist dann Kinder Schokolade.
So, den Kinderriegel einfach so ein bisschen
mit dem Sparschäler bearbeiten.
[Musik]
Oh, ich habe meine Hanuta noch nicht geschnitten.
Oh mein Gott! Schnell, bevor die Kuvertüre fest wird!!!
Oh mein Gott! Bereitet euch die Toppings vor, bevor ihr ihn eintaucht.
Vorbereiten vor dem Eintunken.
Hmm, so oder so?
SARAH: So!
SALLY: So? [Lacht]
JOSH: Alter!
SALLY: Und noch einmal, gell?
[Zustimmung auf dem Hintergrund]
SARAH: Da nur zwei Stückchen.
SALLY: Nur zwei? Die zwei kleinen?
[Musik]
Weiter geht es mit der weißen Schokolade!
Bei der weißen Schokolade habe ich
Lotus-Kekse, Toffifee und Baklava Pistazie.
Wie mache ich das hier? Ich zerbrösele sie.
Genau, immer erst die Toppings vorbereiten!
[Musik]
So, letzte Kombi: Ruby.
MURAT: Warte, warte, warte, warte! Jetzt ohne Spaß.
Iss das einmal, bitte!
SALLY: Woher hast du das?
MURAT: Das lag bei mir auf dem Tisch.
Keine Ahnung, wo das hergekommen ist. Wir haben es gerade gegessen.
Das schmeckt so hammermäßig!
Ich weiß, das sieht auch alles cool aus. Was ist das denn alles?
SALLY: Ich habe gerade 24 Stück Cheesecake
mit 4 verschiedenen Schokoladen und 12 verschiedenen Toppings...
MURAT: Ich glaube es ja, aber bitte, bitte iss das mal!
Bitte, jetzt iss es mal wirklich!
Wir haben es gerade gegessen und fragen uns, wo das Ding herkommt.
Weiß jemand, wo das Ding herkommt?
SALLY: Das riecht nach Bäcker.
MURAT: Ja, das kommt vom Bäcker, aber iss mal!
Krass, oder?
SALLY: Das ist doch ein Plundergebäck mit Nuss.
MURAT: Mit Karamell, merkst du das nicht?
Kannst du das auch mal machen?
[Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Mache ich!
MURAT: Hammer!
SALLY: Mmh! Schmeckt echt gut.
MURAT: Richtig gut, gell?
[Sally stimmt zu]
Ich meine, das ist nicht gesund,
aber alles, was nicht gesund ist, schmeckt irgendwie gut.
Und wenn es nicht gut schmeckt, dann muss es gesund sein.
SALLY: Ich habe Erdbeeren.
MURAT: Hammer! Mach das mal bitte nach, okay?
SALLY: Okay.
MURAT: Sonst mache ich das nach.
SALLY: Können wir auch machen. Josh freut sich.
MURAT: Viel Spaß beim Video. Ich gehe wieder rüber.
SALLY: Du kommst gleich zum Probieren, gell?
[Murat stimmt zu]
Magst du einmal bei einem dabeibleiben?
Ich hätte auch einfach Murats Nussschnecke oben drauflegen können.
[Lacht] Auf so einem Käsekuchen.
Oh, so Cinnamon Rolls... Okay, es eskaliert. Es eskaliert.
Also, Ruby Schokolade:
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wisst,
aber Ruby ist ja die vierte Schokoladensorte unter den Schokoladen.
Vollmilch, Zartbitter, weiße Schokolade.
Ruby ist praktisch von Natur aus schon rosa.
Sie wird nicht rosa gefärbt, sondern sie ist so.
Die Kakaobohne ist rosa.
Dann fügt man einfach nur noch Zitronensäure dazu,
damit sie die Rosafarbe behält. Richtig schön!
Vielleicht werden wir irgendwann einmal euch zeigen,
wie man Schokolade herstellt. Ja!
Okay, eine Ruby Schokolade als Überzug.
Dann Erdbeeren und weiße Schokobons.
Zweite Version: Kinder Pingui in Kirschversion.
Dritte Version: Raffaello mit gefriergetrockneten Himbeeren. Puh!
Okay, ich werde die Erdbeeren halbieren.
Ja, so sieht das schön aus.
Also heute habe ich zum ersten Mal etwas getan,
was ich normalerweise nicht mache, und zwar
Erdbeeren kaufen außerhalb der Saison,
aber für dieses Video musste ich.
Ansonsten warte ich wieder auf die Erdbeeren von Bauer Klaus.
[Musik]
Und Raffaello Himbeere.
MURAT: Mein Gott, das läuft wie bei der Tagesschau.
Immer wenn ich im Leben etwas vorhabe,
dann störst du mich immer bei der Tagesschau.
SALLY: Ja, lieber keine Nachrichten
MURAT: Käsekuchen!
SALLY: Ja, das habe ich heute gebacken.
[Murat stimmt zu]
Heute gibt es Käsekuchen.
MURAT: Den ganzen Tag wegen Käsekuchen. 20 Minuten...
SALLY: Warte! Käsekuchen mit Topping.
MURAT: Krass!
SALLY: Probieren?
[Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Mmh! Lecker! Käsekuchen... [Lacht]
SALLY: Käsekuchen...
MURAT: Was ist denn das?
SALLY: Eis am Stiel.
Ich habe einen hellen und dunklen Schokokäsekuchen.
MURAT: Jetzt müssen wir den Zuschauern auch das Wahre sagen,
und zwar:
Diese Sendung ist gesponsert vom Adipositas-Verband in Bochum
und von der Zahnärztekammer in Reutlingen.
Grüße gehen raus,
und auch an die Weight Watchers gehen Grüße raus.
SALLY: Ja, nachdem ihr nämlich das gegessen habt,
braucht ihr die Weight Watchers.
MURAT: Wahnsinn!
SALLY: Oder auch alle anderen Sportprogramme.
MURAT: Das sind jetzt alles... Es ist nicht gesund.
Also ihr macht so etwas daheim nicht jeden Tag.
SALLY: Es ist nicht gesund.
Also eines muss ich sagen. Bei uns ist jetzt wirklich 20 Uhr.
Ich habe heute den ganzen Tag gedreht.
Ich habe ja auch noch eine andere Torte gemacht.
Im Prinzip war es bei mir jetzt
- jetzt gehen schon alle Rollläden um 20 Uhr runter.
Im Prinzip war es bei mir so aufwendig,
weil ich vier verschiedene Schokoladensorten gemacht habe
und euch praktisch 12 verschiedene Toppings gezeigt habe.
Aber wenn ihr euch eine Sorte mit einer Schokoladensorte auswählt,
dann geht es eigentlich relativ schnell.
Man backt den Käsekuchen am Tag vorher,
friert die Stücke ein und kann dann beim Topping sich mega austoben.
Mit einer oder maximal zwei Schokosorten, finde ich, geht es auch.
Ich finde diese Kombination - ich weiß, dass es Ruby ist.
Ich liebe Karamell über alles und jetzt weiß ich gerade selber nicht.
Ich mag Hanuta - hätte ich gerade voll Bock darauf, Lotus cool...
SALLY: Ich weiß, alles ist gut.
MURAT: Bounty ist cool. Das ist krass.
SALLY: Was ich noch dazu sagen will -
ich habe es vor ein paar Woche schon einmal gesagt:
Bei der Kuvertüre bitte darauf achten, dass es eine gute Kuvertüre ist,
die einfach, auch wenn sie temperiert ist, formfest bleibt,
sich leicht temperieren lässt und einfach von der Qualität her stimmt.
Ich muss sagen, deswegen fiel es mir auch leicht.
Es hat nichts einen grauen Schleier, alles sieht perfekt aus!
MURAT: Und das ist Trend momentan, oder wie?
SALLY: Nein, eigentlich nicht. Ich habe tatsächlich die Idee gesehen,
weil ein Laden eröffnet hat - so ein Cheesecake Laden.
Und dann habe ich gedacht: Das wird jetzt der Kuchentrend 2021.
MURAT: Okay, also:
Das ist jetzt offiziell - letztes Jahr war es was nochmal?
SALLY: Letztes Jahr war es der Bolo Tsunami Cake
MURAT: Genau! Letztes Jahr war es der Bolo Tsunami Cake.
und dieses Jahr ist der Kuchentrend genau das hier!
SALLY: Cheesecake am Stiel -
Käsekuchen am Stiel mit Schokolade und Toppings.
MURAT: Wahnsinn! Also jetzt seid ihr durch.
Jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid, was dieses Jahr der Kuchentrend ist.
Und das sieht alles genial aus. Boah!!
SALLY: Ich muss dir nur leider...
MURAT: Kannst du es auch... Gesund gibt es das nicht, gell?
SALLY: Nein.
Ah, ihr könnt ja auch als Käsekuchen meinen Proteinkuchen reinmachen.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Dann ist der Kern zumindest gesund.
MURAT: Wow! Das schmeckt richtig lecker. Was ist das?
SALLY: Das ist eine Kokosnuss.
MURAT: Wow, eine Kokosnuss!
SALLY: Mir wäre es nur wichtig,
weil wir sind noch draußen an den Fotos dran -
Sarah macht nämlich zu jedem ein Foto, das heißt 12 verschiedene Sets.
Deswegen lass uns bitte hier die angeschnittenen probieren.
MURAT: Und wenn ihr ein Café, Restaurant oder sowas habt -
eine geniale Geschichte. Macht es auf jeden Fall nach!
SALLY: Man kann es perfekt vorbereiten, denn ihr könnt jetzt auch -
ich habe gestern noch einmal zwei Käsekuchen gebacken.
Ich kann die jetzt einfach einfrieren
und habe den Käsekuchen auf Vorrat und kann jederzeit,
egal, ob sich spontan jemand ankündigt oder nicht
oder ich Lust auf den Käsekuchen am Stiel habe,
kann ich jederzeit Käsekuchen am Stiel machen.
MURAT: Und was würde es ungefähr kosten?
Also in Amerika, weiß ich ganz genau:
So ein Ding kostet $10, mindestens, mindestens!
SALLY: Würde ich hier in Deutschland auch schon mit Toppings so...
MURAT: 4 €?
SALLY: Nein, schon zwischen 8 und 10 €.
MURAT: Oh, ehrlich jetzt?
SALLY: Das Stück, ja!
MURAT: Okay.
SALLY: Ja allein hochwertige Schokolade, hochwertige Zutaten,
Süßigkeiten - Marken!
MURAT: Einmal im Jahr könnt ihr das machen.
SALLY: Komm, jetzt probier' doch! Mein Gott!
MURAT: Okay.
SALLY: Also ich will Ruby probieren. Du?
MURAT: Das da. Ich esse das hier.
SALLY: [Stimmt zu] Hau rein! Ich probiere hier.
MURAT: Boah! Mmh! Ich liebe Ruby - ist so säuerlich. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Süß-säuerlich.
[Murat stimmt zu]
Aber eigentlich isst man den schon aus der Hand, oder?
Was würdest du sagen?
MURAT: Ich würde ihn aus der Hand essen, ja!
SALLY: Boah lecker!
MURAT: Hmm! Okay.
Ich würde aber auch gerne das Hanuta oder das Lotus...
SALLY: Okay, aber dann musst du ein bisschen warten.
denn wir machen jetzt erst die Bilder. Komm, beiß mal hier rein!
MURAT: Wo?
Mmh! Hammer!
SALLY: Gut, gell?
MURAT: Hmm! Hammer! Also der Kuchentrend 2021.
Wie nennt sich das jetzt?
SALLY: Der Kuchentrend 2021 ist Käsekuchen am Stiel mit Topping.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Ja. Probiert es gerne aus.
Das Rezept findet ihr wie immer in meiner App - die ist kostenlos.
Dürft ihr euch gern kostenlos herunterladen.
Da könnt ihr nämlich auch die Mengen hoch- und runterrechnen.
Ich werde euch da die Rezepte alle einzeln anlegen
und dann findet ihr da alles auf einmal.
Könnt eine Einkaufsliste erstellen, könnt die Einkaufsliste
eurem Mann, eurem Freund, eurer Freundin schicken.
Er geht einkaufen.
MURAT: Wer?
SALLY: Dann könnt ihr den Kuchen nachbacken.
MURAT: Wer geht einkaufen?
SALLY: Nein, nur so gesprochen.
MURAT: Ach so. Okay.
SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Backen. Bis zum nächsten Mal!
MURAT: Tschüss. Ja.
SALLY: Ich habe jetzt 24...
MURAT: Schon süß, gell?
SALLY: ... 24, sortiere sie.
Aber ich finde, der Käsekuchenkern ist nicht so süß.
Ich habe den extra weniger süß gemacht.
MURAT: Echt?
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Okay. Also ich fand es jetzt echt süß.
SALLY: Ich finde es gut.
MURAT: Ja.
Also...
SARAH: Nein!
MURAT: Nicht essen? [Sally verneint]
Das auch?
SARAH, SALLY UND JOSH: Nein!
MURAT: Dann... Warte, Kokosnuss schmeckt auch lecker.
SALLY UND MURAT: Tschüss.
[Musik]